-Some sports news, guys.
The new NBA season
tipped off tonight.
And -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The new NBA season tipped off
tonight with 30 teams
competing for a championship.
We thought we'd welcome
the new season
with a song
about the team logos.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ The New York Knicks
have a basketball ♪
♪ The Toronto Raptors
♪ The Miami Heat
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Phoenix Suns
♪ Well, the Indiana Pacers
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Brooklyn Nets
♪ The Orlando Magic
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Portland Trail Blazers
have a... ♪
Okay, let's move on.
♪ The Dallas Mavericks
have a basketball ♪
♪ While the Utah Jazz,
they have a basketball ♪
♪ Well, the Detroit Pistons
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Portland Trail Blazers
have... ♪
Oh, geez. Not this again.
Let's circle back.
♪ The Timberwolves
have a basketball ♪
♪ While the LA Clippers
♪ And the Portland Trail Blazers
have a... ♪
Oh, God. Okay. You know,
let's just figure this out.
♪ It's a real bad
drawing of a candy cane ♪
♪ It's a comma and apostrophe
doing a thing ♪
♪ It's Picasso's version
of a hurricane ♪
♪ It's Ed Sheeran
going down a drain ♪
♪ It's Donald Trump's hair
with a chicken's wing ♪
♪ It's a 69,
don't want to be profane ♪
♪ Man, I don't know
what it is at all ♪
♪ All I know is
it ain't a basketball ♪
♪ Hey, Tariq, let me ask you,
what is this thing? ♪
♪ Do you have a clue? ♪
-♪ Well, it's weird
and it's round ♪
♪ And it's red and it's white ♪
♪ Kind of looks like a cookie ♪
♪ I'm gonna take a bite ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]